a family's call for justice two years
after a man was murdered in las vegas
thank you for joining us on 8 news now
at 11 i'm brian loftis and i'm denise
valdez twain allen jr was shot and
killed in the southwest valley in
september of 2019. his mother and fiance
sat down with our sasha loftis as they
continue to search for answers she joins
us live with a story you will only see
on 8 news now
denise and brian t wayne's family says
they would not wish this pain on anyone
after all this time they still don't
know who killed him now they're calling
on the community for help
i want justice for my child it's been
just over 730 days since angela cook
last saw her son i miss a smile ebony
jones has spent the same amount of time
learning to live without her fiance life
without t wayne allen never imagined it
t wayne allen jr was just 31 when he was
killed
a prominent performer wrapping under the
stage named t-crace
on september 15 2019 allen was shot at
this apartment complex in the southwest
valley and later died at umc two men
were seen running from the area but no
suspects were found and his family is
still searching for closure i designed
these shoes for my son his mother even
designed a t-crazed shoe line that's
since raised 50 thousand dollars worth
of reward money for any information
leading to an arrest i have a hole in my
heart she and ebony hope these answers
will bring them some semblance of peace
people say it gets better but i like i
always mention that's the worst lie
anybody could tell so they can remember
this man they loved
for the life he lived and the joy he
brought to their world
metro police tell us this case is still
under investigation if you have any
information you can contact metro's
homicide department or contact crime
stoppers to remain anonymous reporting
live in the newsroom tonight sasha
loftis live local now